MISSISSIPPI DIDN’T OFFICIALLY OUTLAW SLAVERY
UNTIL 1995
While the Thirteenth Amendment was set into
law, thus outlawing slavery anywhere in the
United States, on December 6, 1865 when it
secured the needed 27 of 36 states’ approval
(3/4), it wasn’t until 130 years later on
March 16, 1995 that Mississippi finally got
around to ratifying the Thirteenth Amendment.
As you might expect, this made Mississippi
the last state to ratify it, with the previous
state of the initial 36 being Kentucky in
1976 and before that Delaware in 1901.
All three of those states, along with New
Jersey, initially rejected the amendment in
1865, though just 9 months after rejecting
it, New Jersey changed their mind and ratified
it.
The others took a little longer.
The Thirteenth Amendment specifically states:
Neither slavery nor involuntary servitude,
except as a punishment for crime whereof the
party shall have been duly convicted, shall
exist within the United States, or any place
subject to their jurisdiction.
Congress shall have power to enforce this
article by appropriate legislation.
Interestingly, The Thirteenth Amendment almost
stated the exact opposite of what it ended
up saying.
A few years before the amendment to abolish
slavery was proposed as the Thirteenth Amendment,
The Corwin Amendment was proposed in 1861
and would have been the Thirteenth Amendment,
had 3/4 of the states ratified it.
This proposed amendment would have forbid
Congress from passing any laws that restricted
or abolished slavery.
Further, it would have made it illegal for
any anti-slavery amendment to be made to the
U.S. Constitution.
Specifically, it stated:
No amendment shall be made to the Constitution
which will authorize or give to Congress the
power to abolish or interfere, within any
State, with the domestic institutions thereof,
including that of persons held to labor or
service by the laws of said State.
This Corwin Amendment managed to make it passed
the House and the Senate in March of 1861
and was signed by President Buchanan thereafter.
Ohio, Maryland, and Illinois ratified it.
Although, once the American Civil War started,
the Corwin Amendment lost any momentum it
had, because it had largely been proposed
to forestall the chance of a Civil War.
Once the war started, Ohio rescinded their
ratification.
The Corwin Amendment was passed without an
expiration, so it’s still on the table today
for states to ratify, if they so choose.
The most recent attempt to do so was in Texas
in 1963, with a resolution to ratify it put
forth by Republican Henry Stollenwerck from
Dallas.
This failed to generate any momentum for the
Corwin Amendment, though, and the resolution
wasn’t considered by the state legislature.
If you’re curious, there are some exceptions
to that “involuntary servitude” bit in
the Thirteenth Amendment beyond as a “form
of punishment”.
For instance, the Supreme Court ruled in 1918
that the military draft does not constitute
“involuntary servitude”, even if the people
drafted do not want to join the military.
This seems to fly in the face of the generally
accepted legal definition of involuntary servitude
which includes, “a person held by actual
force, threats of force, or threats of legal
coercion in a condition of slavery – compulsory
service or labor against his or her will.”
This case was brought before the Supreme Court
after the passing of the Conscription Act
of 1917.
After this Act was passed, military tribunals
tried various people who refused to bear arms,
wear uniforms, etc. when drafted.
More shockingly, a board was put together
to try consciousness objectors.
The only people at this time who were allowed
to be conscientious objectors were Amish,
Quakers, and members of the Church of the
Brethren.
If the board decided they weren’t sincere
enough, they were sentenced.
These were no light sentences either, 17 people
were sentenced to death, 142 were given life
sentences in prison, and 345 were sentenced
to penal labor camps for varying time periods.
The Supreme Court unanimously upheld the Conscription
Act of 1917, citing Article I. Section 9,
of the Constitution which gives Congress the
power to “declare war… to raise and support
armies… to make rules for the government
and regulation of the land and naval forces.”
Of course, this says nothing about the government
being able to force people to join the military,
only that they have the authority to build
and support the armies.
But, none-the-less, they upheld it anyways,
further citing Vattel’s, The Law of Nations:
It may not be doubted that the very conception
of a just government and its duty to the citizen
includes the reciprocal obligation of the
citizen to render military service in case
of need, and the right to compel it.
… To do more than state the proposition
is absolutely unnecessary in view of the practical
illustration afforded by the almost universal
legislation to that effect now
in force.